this week we've got coffin challenge
student driver and fart breath new
weekend shambles long ago oh yeah I like
this one
it sounds like sandstorm we should it
should be salt on iTunes I really
believe that alright so for our first
story this Six Flags in Missouri they
have just recently posted a challenge to
their guests in honor of their yearly
Fright Fest celebration which is now 30
years and they're saying that if you can
lie in a coffin for 30 hours you might
win $300 and that coffin that's it but
you might not that's it so that's $10 an
hour yeah coffin for laying down that's
tight I want that job yeah yeah but can
you do anything while you're in there
like so they are so charged taxes
oh yeah good point so they're saying
that this coffin is two by seven and
that it's slightly used oh that's weird
they took a dead body on it by who
probably those like cremated people that
they had like a wake and then they use
the coffin for the weight the way that
they were like make it sound slightly
uses like it was a prop or something
like that
I thought dead body first maybe it's
they they put someone like Steve's
height in there that all he doesn't fit
do you think that anyone has ever missed
miss sized a coffin and then they just
saw guys shove the shoes at the bottom
and nobody's going to shake I think the
old days they did I think about that
every day I swear to god I'll glue it
all or the day you married yes it's like
I don't want people to spend too much
money on my funeral just buy me a kid's
casket saw me in half you do both sides
viewable so one side your shoes in one
size your head yeah squeeze me down and
then put the shoe and yeah cremated yeah
part of funeral is when we're sawing you
and happened then we split it huh
Oh like a magic yeah like during is like
a show and they spin both sides and you
open the plate and in its actual guts
and [ __ ] fun fun fun yeah okay so it's
you might win 300 yards after 30 hours
yep so they're saying that well first of
all there is a six it might happen yes
there's a 6 minute bathroom break every
hour oh cool all meals and snacks and
drinks are provided by the park oh
there's phone charging stations that
will be available so you can just use
your phone the phone so it's like being
coach on air yeah 30 hours 30 hours is
pretty tough it's like I'm flying to
Bangladesh
yeah they're feeding you you get to go
to the bathroom and you get to be on
your phone yeah 30 hours though well the
reason why it's a might is because if
there's more than one person that makes
it through the whole 30 hours then
they're gonna raffle off the names and
see who's a real winner know that spend
all that time there go through all that
[ __ ] and stuff you got to go until the
last person taps out that's it that's
the American Way
yeah thirty hours right it's got to be
survival they didn't have a higher
budget to get more coffee they need to
take away some of the luxuries then yeah
like no fool every 30 hours they take
away one more things no conjugal visit
one water bottle for the whole three
hours they need to get an old coffin
that's been used for like maybe maybe
some some family's not paying for the
bill right and then so they can dig up
this body and you're there with them no
no no so this so you dig up the coffin
right and it's actually used and then
you move the body out of it and then you
use this coffin where it smells like
dead body and then you have to be in
there like that there's a coffin repo
man that's like you didn't pay the bill
this month property like that you own a
like a like a property yeah my world
mind in my world it's like real estate
okay we're gonna repo this [ __ ] cuz
they're not paying their [ __ ] space
why don't they put you in there with an
actual dead body that's one thing that's
unsanitary is it yeah they're dead
what have they got cleaned up and all
nice and I don't think you're never
fully clothed and all the insects ate it
all it's all offense what if it was
embalmed and it's a fresh dead body
that's what we want though the scary
Halloween sound you want a challenge
what if it was Joe cut in half in his
infant coffee and you got to try to
figure self in there the face of your
loved one no you know the one I was
going to tell you guys when my grandpa
passed I helped like my my aunt two of
my aunts and my uncle and my cousin like
we all wanted to help like dress him for
the funeral cause it was like our final
like goodbye to him because we didn't
get to see him before you bet and like
we were helping and like his bones were
like all cracking
this is not my grandpa anymore yeah they
do with that like I don't know like I
only had one pet died on me and like it
was wouldn't even allow that in the u.s.
I don't know but this isn't TJ and then
would they also had this thing for his
his wake
they allowed us to stay there overnight
like an entire night of being with him
yeah whoo we did so they were like we
were sleeping and like the the area no
no no no no no no you don't get away
with that you're sleeping in one area
like I forgot what it was like in the
room yeah in the room with the dead body
his body is yeah Wow so did these
Funeral Homes have like slumber party
rooms pretty much well is this a Mexican
how was it I think it's a Mexican what
was that like it was really interesting
I mean it was also kind of like very
like therapeutic in a sense cuz we were
like saying goodbye to him and we were
just sharing all of our stories with him
throughout the whole night because like
we're trying to stay up the whole night
good do it with the picture pretty much
he makes a good voice we'd like the
craziest part think cuz you know how
like Mexicans were really superstitious
too and like you know like we believe in
spirits and all that stuff and there was
this moment throughout the night where
to my uncle's like their brothers they
were fighting like Mir with my where my
grandpa was about some stuff and then
the glass cuz if they had put a glass
over his body the glass like cracked it
was kind of like I'm going to stop
fighting everyone was like that's my
grandpa telling you guys to stop by in
Filipinos are like that too yeah like my
dad everybody the spirit every time
there's a fly that comes in the door my
dad thinks it's my grandpa papa it was
like it's a [ __ ] fly you immediately
like but then I was at my cousin's
wedding and this fly wouldn't leave us
alone it was just going through
everybody and I was like oh man this
paparazzi my grandpa my grandpa was here
everyone being peaceful in a room with
the glass over his head and he would
break it because he wants everyone to
fight exactly you want some kind of
tension happening but it was really
because my grandpa look like I mean you
know you see what you want to see but it
look like he had like this like a smile
anyways moving on to the next story so
there's this
Indiana bus driver Indiana's at the
beginning let's go calls this bus driver
her name is Joe Andrea she's 27 years
old
she that's her first name Joe Andrea Joe
Andrea one word there's been so many
name combinations these days huh yeah
it's an epidemic
yeah Joe Andrea's I was the other one
that was really weird
it was like basica yeah it was something
like that like Bethany and Jessica or
like Beth yeah like it was like Seneca
or some [ __ ] like that yeah so this one
though Joe Andrea what she did is she
let three students ages 11 13 and 17
drive the bus
oh that's their videos she's the one
recording the video why is that bad buzz
by themselves yes how do they reach the
pedals I don't know you couldn't read
your tape you're tall enough you can
write even I was taught to drive an 11-5
team Oh getaway car away no like you
know was it my parents but my parents
let me drive around to have me on their
lap and they're pressing the pedal and
I'm like full of drag but that's like at
eight right yeah that's really scary
you're probably still doing this while
you have it me is like on the wheel you
know how like yeah yeah so like I'm on
the lap I'm thinking I'm driving his
knee is really bad it's like when I gave
my brother and unplug controller in
Mario Kart that little [ __ ]
really thought explain Mario Kart right
here let me show you guys this video
don't tell no other adults about her
okay he was recording the kids the one
in the bus so that's that one this other
one I'm actually driving oh oh it's on
the real street I thought it was in like
a parking boy it's part of her route no
they're going very slowly Ryan don't
freak out Ryan they're going very slow
she's like I told him not to tell any
other adult hello it's all right it's
all right so I wanna know who knocked on
her I think that's pretty messed up well
a parent found on the kit on the kids to
haul were the kids again 11 13 and 17
the kid pice smoking with their parents
13 and 17 I feel like it's cool they're
almost at the age and they're gonna yeah
yeah 17 you definitely yeah 17 yeah 13
is almost is 4 I think you have to be 14
to get the permit 15 15 a have 15 and a
half for the permit they too usually
those 14 when I got my 15 I have 50 and
a half when I was you're younger than me
though where you're ruthless oh then I
don't know because I remember I was 14
how old are you at sixth grade sixth
grade should be like 11 like 12 or 11 my
friend had a paper route and then his
sister who's in sixth grade and my
friend is like in fourth or fifth grade
she would take the family van and then
take him on his paper route and you
would just throw the paper out like the
sliding door and she's just so she's
like 11 or 12 driving friend who's like
8 or 9 and they lived to tell the tale
yeah [ __ ] yeah we'll have another parent
maybe they didn't want to wake up like I
remember it's not the last children yeah
and I remember like we had a like a like
a family
not a family farm but if our friends
family had a farm and then they let me
learn how to ride a light like run the
tractor and then like run it through in
like I didn't do any work but they let
me ride it through the field
all that that's different though oh yeah
that's but I was like Ted my mind is
different though cuz that's like
probably nothing to hit please no man's
land
yeah hey but I learned how to drive like
a car in a parking lot like before the
legal age of 13 my mom used to my
grandma used to tell my mom to go get
groceries when she was like 13 and she
would take the car and she would use my
grandma's ID I yeah the grocer never
even questioned there how old was your
friend driving on the mini and then
paper up she was like 12 or 11
holy yeah well that was his big sister
but my friend was like eight or nine so
it's a it's an 11 year old driving and
then you see in like that's like a scene
in a movie where I'm a homeless guy
sitting on a bench and I'm drinking like
something and I look over and I see an
11 and I see an 8 you're all throwing
[ __ ] out of the thing and I'm like no
not drinking this like holy [ __ ] I think
I saw an 11 year old driving I would
just think it's like a young looking
girl like cuz girls just look yeah like
you I've seen older girls look like they
were 12 I've seen young girls look like
they were 30 I've seen 30 year olds look
like they're 20 trying to get trying to
get laid you gotta find the right age
though you can't be like I seen 30 year
olds that look 1440p I'll say that one
alright for our last story part
something yeah fart breath for it breath
so this professor of nutrition and
dietetics day-to-day etics
thank you they annex maybe Dianetics
diet Etsy it's a divine I love not even
Nikki Karina but all the common ters
will know cuz they're actually know of
everything so Jesus is most
passive-aggressive they know everything
don't they know anytime you make a
slight mistake everyone in the comments
like what [ __ ] idiot
you can't even for no it's not what else
are they gonna do like three losers that
Cuba we know every single word of the
dictionary losers people who point out
mistakes if they're on YouTube yes
anyway so this professor at the
University of Newcastle says that if
you're holding your fart it will leak
out of your mouth yeah we actually says
that that's real that's is that the same
thing as like if you hold in your piss
it'll sweat out your pores well I've
never heard that I've never heard that I
got some Saudi s hands you don't smell
like piss - I had sweaty hands you do
you have moist hands see we had this
conversation yesterday and I was like
they're clammy
they are anyways like no they're not and
I've said it before - I'm like look this
is a dry hands you're right girls like
clammy
no you know why it's tonight it's
because when I stopped by with Gio like
to get a little spray you know what you
know girls don't fart or whatever you
don't supposed to say that but I
honestly like don't ever have the part I
used to always walk I love this woman
but I don't like that truth feed other
I've never heard a fart one time in my
life
she was lots of gross [ __ ] but like huh
really I mean I've definitely done it
before
like hi dude you are human oh yeah what
very few I'm human but I do you burp
them no or do you fart when you're
taking this [ __ ] because that's usually
where most of my farts
maybe I don't I don't [ __ ] where does
that come on there's guys out there who
love the the
this shows getting farted in their face
all right what does that call [ __ ]
hilarious
oh wait about that video cake farts oh
yeah oh yeah
I think that's where I heard about it
initially yeah like cake farts ooh
number it's like this girl sitting on a
cake and it's like she's party on a cake
and that people eat it after no and guys
just jerk off watching her for like a
baby that's the next level well there's
also the [ __ ] where chicks just sit on
balloons and pop yeah I wish I could get
turned on by things like that I want to
know what that feels me too it's like Oh
Oh whoopee cushion oh my god
you know I think that's so weird I used
to get turned on as a kid you know
before I knew about sexuality or
whatever whenever a cartoon character
was like getting tied up Fievel goes
west the bad guy rolls him up in like a
burrito like it rolls him up in a
tortilla and I was like I got so turned
on by that
so that's how girls get into that rope
thing that you know that Japanese rope
thing it's like a very specific like
knot tying
yeah but like that doesn't turn me on
mmm I think it was like really
comforting my way he was wrapped in a
burrito and I was like oh he can't go
anywhere it's not tying it's just like
you should so you should get a big
Persian rug and in both of you and Steve
later middle like this I didn't get
[ __ ] wrap around no you know what it
was is that he can't move but it's not
uncomfortable so like I don't want to be
it looks like a sleeping bag yeah it's
like comfy can't really apply this to
your sex life no we do when we talk
about he holds me down but I'm not like
wrapped in like we don't need the extra
that's actually I'm thinking the actual
wrapped in a bird she wants to be
stabilized yeah but then I'm not be able
to move [ __ ] cuz there's no given me no
I can be applied oh yeah there's no or
unless there's two burritos happening
it's your upper body and then your legs
and you put your legs up oh I like that
tip always trying to make it work that's
what's great about you you know what I
pictured I pictured to like bodies that
are wrapped around in Persian rugs right
and there's a cutout for the guy and a
cutout for the girl and then you just
plug the to you so it looks like things
with Ed's going on like this
see we're over here in dreamland and
you're over there making it work yeah
this is PI it up and then this is side
up and then the wood jaw got the full
design Doug you know me I got to see
schematics yeah mine isn't sexy but it
works
reminds me of Dexter you know he's got
saran wrap here saran wrap here I like a
feeling like a [ __ ] leftover turkey I
mean do you want that do you actually
want that that's a lot of work yeah I
don't think you want them wait so if you
hold it up barred you become fart breath
that's what this kind of just hit me
right now no because this professor said
cuz I quit I gave up holding in my farts
I just [ __ ] do it you do no but you
do run Jess
yeah all the time we're gonna messing
around jazz I'm doing right here too and
I forgetting oh my oh my bad
yeah I'll hear it so you just you
chillin it's like
know what I realized I realize that
farts for me it's like the number one
thing like I just I can't I can't I
can't stand it yeah I don't like it if
the other people are fart around me I'm
like no why that angers me I don't mind
as other people do but I but I don't
like it if my lady does it and I don't
do it around my lady you know what I
don't mind if it's by accident if it's
like oh [ __ ] I can hold it I'm like okay
you're human you know just gotta have
better food combinations you know don't
eat beans mixed with some rice or like
be Mexican some of us just like garlic I
like raw garlic and that's like hell
yeah no it does it does oh you know you
eat a lot of raw garlic and then your
stomach good it's not a general public
me I heard veggies give you gas garlic
is supposed to cleanse you I thought
with the farts mm-hmm yeah when I fart
it feels like all the bad things are
leaving maybe that's what it is I'm
stressed out all the time I'm just so
tightly round that I just can't fart let
escape like it doesn't even feel like I
have to do though it just feels like
well you need a lot of vegetables and
fiber so I'm surprised you don't fart I
do the other she eats eggs out of a
[ __ ] bag I can't believe this [ __ ]
doesn't fart I don't but I don't eat
eggs out of a bag yes she goes Jay
there's hard-boiled eggs in a bag that's
all peeled and that's green it's not a
bag it's in a bath it's in juice and a
plastic thing so we'll be in traffic
they'll package the boy you're the weird
one will be traffic Nicky's driving and
she's reaching in don't leave don't like
you know there's two left
do these two eggs in the city it's
pretty nice
[Music]